physically i feel good i'm in shape
emotionally
that kind of varies on the time in the
moment simone biles withdraws from the
team finals at the tokyo olympics due to
a medical issue
coming here to the olympics and being
the head
star of the olympics is not an easy feat
so we're just trying to take it one day
at a time and we'll see
the 24 year old gymnast opened up to the
today show on tuesday
after she left the competition floor
with the team usa medical trainer
following her first rotation
on the vault of the women's team final
at the tokyo olympics
simone did not do the aminar vault but
opted instead for another move which
earned her
a 13.766 the lowest score of
any of her olympic showings and in a
statement
usa gymnastics said quote simone has
withdrawn from the team final
competition
due to a medical issue she will be
assessed daily to determine medical
clearance for future competitions
reserve jordan chiles replaced simone
after she left the floor
ahead of her uneven bars rotation she
later returned to the arena with her
right leg
wrapped and hugged her teammates who
finished the competition without her and
simone told today how the team handled
the news of her withdrawing
they were freaking out they were like
crying and i was like you guys need to
relax you're going to be fine without me
go out there you kick some butt just
like you've done in training and
just lay it out on the floor and see
what happens earlier this week simone
who already has four olympic gold medals
got candid about the pressures of
competing writing on instagram quote
i truly do feel like i have the weight
of the world on my shoulders at times
i know i brush it off and make it seem
like pressure doesn't affect me but
damn sometimes it's hard something she's
opened up to et about before
whenever we perform we're expected to
win which it can kind of get a lot at
times because
we're so young with such a big amount of
pressure but i think we handle it very
well
and following simone's team finals exit
the today show caught up with three-time
olympic gold medalist ali raisman
who echoed all that too watching like
simone has more pressure than any other
gymnast i've ever seen in my lifetime
it's it's insane how much pressure is on
her um you know
when i saw her with the medic i my heart
dropped and i i was just devastated and
i still am
and while simone may be out of the
competition figuratively she's
already won because she's a top-tier
class act
everyone does strive to be the best and
it is hard whenever
you have a team so good and you have to
compete against each other but then
on the other side we're such good
friends that we're rooting for each
other no matter what and we just want
the best for each other
after withdrawing the athlete stayed and
cheered on her teammates
got them chalked for their hands
encouraged them and hugged them
something retired american artistic
gymnast michaela skinner
and ali talked about with today my heart
broke
for her i mean i can't even imagine what
she's going through right now i wish i
could just run down there and give her a
big hug
i know she's going to hang in there and
you know keep cheering for the team
you know she's human and i think
sometimes people forget that and
simone just like everyone else is doing
the best that she can simone is there
right now cheering for her teammates her
cheering for them is going to help them
out a lot and ally was right
it did help the team went on to earn the
silver
in the final super proud of these girls
that stepped up and did what they needed
to do and now we're
olympic silver medalists so it's
something that they'll cherish forever